bon ben on va le garder banques lagarde
et en plus c'est en direct la guitare et
en direct les micros marche
oui il dira un témoin à la télévision on
chante en choeur en direct est-ce que tu
connais la boudeuse d'avoir le reconnais
je la smala messieurs quitte à faire à
chagrin immense à bruno masure
le nouveau couple de france 2 gérard
holtz
joseph poli ça va jaser wahhab où des
centaines
ce ne sont plus les amours d'autrefois q
caresses sur calais se
et maintenant tu me laisses aux abois ne
lit plus jolis mots je t'aime que si
souvent me disait
pour répondre
réponds moi si tu m'aides aurait pour
moi dis moi que tu es aux réponses
répond moi si tu peux
pour répondre moi dis-moi côté je fais
à
d'une seule le soir en prod
le prendre le frais assis sur le gazon
tu fais semblant d'être toujours malade
dis moi pourquoi rester à la maison
mais plus
que ce soit dans ses toilettes
et tu n'as plus c'est ainsi gracieux
tout le
en même temps que tu es jolie de
lancieux
quand
tu me tourner la planète
en même temps
c'est joli
noël est certaine malaise
you i désunis
les avants si souvent j'étais monte est
trop bien creux du long de jalousie
rappelle toi
emoze des serments te vois tu pas se
décolore
hpd
je le jure ans
qu'après mon dieu je n'ai c'est vrai
vraiment
je
le jour encore appelé
jugé